all right Mark
where'd you grow up where are you from
where are you from originally from
downtown
you raise your raised downtown yeah
tell me about your family
um well my mom she was on drugs my dad
I didn't know him
um since I was a baby uh it was just my
mom
you know your mom raised you yeah
downtown
on Skid Row yeah that's good as well did
you go to school no
no school at all no school at all my
teachings came from people on the street
and you know here there you know adults
you know we have some questions
you know stuff like that how many years
you been down here
um about 40. how old do you know 52.
new uh
how have you survived what do you do for
money
um hustle um
uh Panhandle
oh
I need a job so I can get them
you know
calm people out of money
um
going to stores
and you know go to the back and get
money
you know run out the back or whatever
you know
what do you stay in attend yeah I stay
in the team how long you've been living
in a town it's about
three or four years
three or four years yeah where were you
before that before that I was um like in
in group homes Mission to jail
stuff like that
you've been in love before have you been
in love before
um yeah once
we're downtown female
you know
that didn't turn out so well
you know because I was got the best of
her
um
you know I knew from prior experience
that I should have
been with a female that's on drugs
you know
do you have children
no no kids
and drugs are part of your life as well
yes
um Christian
do you have any friends
yeah I do I have friends
you know I'll call them friends because
what they did for me and I can go to
them
you know
and they don't Acts no questions you
know if I ask them for something they'll
give it to me
you know only because it's only good
faith that they know who I am as a man
you know
was it was a person need to know
in order to survive on Skid Row
um
for 40 years learn your environment
um
sit back and watch
pay attention
don't be quick too
jump into something or
react to something by what somebody
tells you
you know
investigate stuff yourself
you know the best of your ability
stay away from places that you know they
never been
even if it looks exciting don't go
you know somebody that you know have
them take you
you've had bad things happen to you here
I'm sure yeah yeah
bad experience
you know
but by grace of God
he got me through
the times when I probably shouldn't
still be here
you know you know
I don't take nothing for granted no more
it's a learning experience
for me what's the worst thing you've
seen on Skid Row
well you're cute
a little in front of me it happens all
the time yeah
yeah
every day
if you can make it out of
downtown
then you can make it anywhere
anywhere in the world
yeah what are you afraid of
um
being a statistic
you know being in a wrong place it's a
long time
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
um
refused
refused of drugs
um
I went to my family's house
instead of being downtown
you had an opportunity to go to
someone's house yes and you chose to
stay here and I chose to stay here
through to the drugs
and I couldn't handle them
what do you deal with emotionally
living here you get depressed or angry
or anxious yeah I get all three
inches overwhelming sad
depressed
um
sometimes I feel I'm not worth it
you know why am I here
what's my purpose
you know and I pray
that I get through
whatever it is that I'm going through
you know I didn't believe in the higher
being
but now I do
and
I just lived day by day
I only look forward to tomorrow because
tomorrow has its own life
I use the tools that I've been dealt
with
that I've learned
and try hard to stick to them
do you feel like life is unfair
I don't feel life is unfair
I feel
life is what you make it
but you have your own freedom of
thoughts
your own decisions
sometimes you can't be persuaded
you know
but that's because you don't know
it's the unknown that makes you
quizzitive
and do the wrong thing sometimes
there's no schooling did you do you ever
learn to read and write
yeah pull somebody on the street
yeah the first time to show me
watching
um
TV
when I could
pick up a book every now and when I
could
something I don't understand I'll ask
somebody on the street
and they'll tell me
what do you think you missed out on most
by living here most of your life
the fun things in life
the opportunity to enjoy
what they call a good life
being loved by family
um
having nice things
Mark what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
they would take things for granted
and
not to judge
not what I see
and give everybody a chance
give everybody a chance
I've learned that
it's not about color and race
or
how someone
may seem to
present theyself
and
don't be quick to judge
you know learn
because I learned every day
around every day
all right Mark thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
God bless you thank you